all right guys bang bang i've got mark
here with me mark super excited to talk
about this uh nine months ago it seemed
like everyone was in the froth they were
just uh fomo and into every asset class
we saw everything from trading cards to
stocks uh to you know little nfts all
the way on down uh here we are nine
months later and not so much fomo not so
much froth uh what happened and why
exactly
did this occur
the baby came pump you can relate right
you know leading up to the baby it's all
excitement and everything's euphoric and
you've got all the presents coming in
and then
bang
you know no sleep
and uh you know things are a lot tougher
on the other side now i i think what it
is
is
the little boy who cried wolf
okay right when the boy cries wolf and
the wolf doesn't come everybody says oh
i won't listen the next time and cries
wolf and then and i think this time the
fed actually
turned into the wolf you know it's
interesting when when powell
came in
you know he was jerome the hawk
you know he all the cartoons were him
with the hawk body and
and then he became jay jay
the dove
right when trump kind of put you know
the needle in and said hey you got to
help me with the market and he backed
off in 18 on on his hey i'm going to
raise interest rates
and the market rallied well by 2020
i mean he was jay just the letter j the
pusher in the hoodie on the corner
passing out you know hits the steroids
to everybody
so
i don't think anyone thought
jerome the hawk would come back
i don't think anybody thought
the markets
would also
do his job for him
in the sense that by the time he raised
the second 50 basis points up to 75
the market had already tightened two and
a half points i mean we had the greatest
tightening of liquidity in the last
hundred years
so i think that's what changed so this
is a great point in that uh a lot of
folks will argue that uh the way that we
talk about inflation can create
inflation so if everyone starts yelling
and screaming inflation's coming
inflation's coming then actually some
business owners or maybe even many of
them will raise prices in anticipation
and that in turn creates inflation
it seems like
the fed tried to do the opposite and
talk the market down and kind of talk
tough
and
the longer that they did that
without actually raising rates to your
point there was a little bit of like the
boy cried wolf
do you think that there's any weight or
ability for them to actually talk tough
enough to get the market to move or does
the market only care about actions
it's the perfect it's the perfect
question
here's here's what i've been saying for
the last couple months is
you know the fed
didn't create
the
inflation that we're all feeling
uh and they can't fix it
right how many basis points
are going to restore
the supply chains in china how many
basis points of tightening are going to
get all those ships stranded off the
ports to unload and reload to come back
here
how many
you know basis points is gonna stop the
craziness on people locking down and
halting parts of the economy
no way
and so that's the first part and i will
also make the case that
the inflation that we see
isn't
inflation the way most people are
talking about it trying to compare this
to the 70s
this is nothing like the 70s right 70s
was about demand pole inflation where
there was excess demand
and limited supplies and then then
really a big problem with the iran
contra scandal and the the saudi
pullback in oil
and oil prices spiked and then on top of
it
there was a
problem in the way they measured cpi
back there back then in that it double
counted
uh
interest rates and
house prices and so volcker who you know
everybody says oh he beat the you know
beat inflation he was actually causing
the problem he was looking at bad data
raising interest rates which was then
feeding back into the data raising so it
was
he didn't really beat it per se it was
just it got so high that people just
said oh geez i'm done right i won't do
anything at 20 prime rate
the difference is this time we don't
have demand pull inflation we don't have
good demographics we don't have uh low
levels of debt so people can lever up
and start businesses we have the exact
opposite we have crappy demographics you
know people turn to 65 every single day
10 000 of them in this country every
single day for the next seven years
and 65 to 85 year old people don't spend
a lot they don't you know uh they're not
as productive the way we measure
productivity
we have way too much debt debt is
deflationary not inflationary
the real problem we have is currency
debauchement
what happened two years ago
is we had the
buffoon move
by whoever the wephites to lock down the
world
absolute insanity i mean literal
insanity
and because of that
the reaction from global central bankers
was print print print printer in print
because the cult of kelton right the
stephanie kelton you know modern
monetary theory people modern monetary
madness people decided that oh we can
print as much as we want it won't matter
well no of course it matters
right you used to live down here in
north carolina where i am now
houses houses are up 40 4-0 in 12 months
my house did not grow it did not get
more efficient it actually cost me money
i have to put money into the house to
keep it a certain level
it's not worth 40 more the currency in
which i value it is worth 40 less
that's not inflation the way they want
us to believe
that inflation is good for us the prices
rise in a controlled way that's just
currency debasement
when i think about this what's so
fascinating is if you just take it to
the extreme and i forget who i heard say
this but i thought it was so
just so articulate if the debt doesn't
matter if the printing of money doesn't
matter then let's just print three
quadrillion dollars
right like if it literally doesn't
matter then like let's just add a bunch
more zeros to the end when we're
printing and rather than have two
trillion dollar uh you know stimulus
bills let's literally just do a two
quadrillion stimulus bill now obviously
nobody who is sane or uh serious would
ever actually argue to do that
because it does matter to some degree
and no come on if it was that easy pom
we've talked about this you know when we
first met
if
if creating wealth
was as simple as printing money
wouldn't everyone do that wouldn't every
country just print money
that's not how wealth is created right i
mean i have in my office i go get it for
you a 100 trillion zimbabwe dollar bill
wouldn't buy a loaf of bread
100 trillion dollars
right that i own i couldn't buy a loaf
of bread in zimbabwe so how many
bolivars does it take to buy a chicken
in venezuela how many pesos in argentina
you know it's just this fallacy
that debt and deficits don't oh but
we're the world reserve currency
well
for now
you know the uk was the world reserve
currency for 75 years
and they thought they could spend as
much as they wanted
just like we do and they thought they
could invade anybody they wanted to just
like we do and in 1913 they invaded
mesopotamia
incurred a bunch of debt the pound
started collapsed the dollar ascended 30
years later bretton woods we became the
world reserve currency then
coincidentally we invaded mesopotamia
incurred a bunch of debt the dollar
collapsed the remnant be ascended china
became oh wait that hasn't happened yet
it will
you think you think that the chinese
reinman b will end up being the global
reserve currency
yep
walk me through kind of what the the
thought process of where we are today to
how we get there yeah so
um
profitly get spending
in the us right all empires fail the
same way whether it's the british empire
the roman empire the ottoman empire they
all failed the same way through massive
amounts of debt when you become
massively indebted you only got four
choices you can pay it back
you couldn't do that right you could tax
the assets of all the people in the
united states their wealth forget their
income
tax all their wealth you couldn't pay
back the debt
all of it can do it so you can't pay it
back so then you can restructure it
problem is if you structure it someone's
got to take the other side no one's
going to take the other side
third you can default on it
emerging markets default all the time
but we can't do that because there's no
imf to bail us out
and oh by the way if you default what
happens you get kicked out of power and
then politicians like to stay in power
fourth you can devalue it and that's
what we will do so we will continue to
devalue says oh the dollar's so strong
the dollar's so strong no it's not
the dollar's down versus the remnb over
the last two years
fact
the dollar only
shows to be up because we compare it to
toilet paper
i mean we compare it to the yen which is
hilarious and we compare to the euro
which is just as bad
and because those went down more dxy
went up
a little bit not even a lot but we are
down versus the rem beat now which is oh
but the last couple weeks you know
whatever
the chinese are playing a different game
they
i believe intentionally
are creating this nonsense you know
supply chain garbage to create a greater
alignment with them
they started with southeast asia and
africa now they've got russia
and they are creating this massive
axis
of alignment that all are going to move
to use the remnb
and
over time the petro dollar system will
weaken
and erode without the petro dollar
system
we're just a little country that does
eight percent of global trade
what is the u.s response in that
scenario so let's say that they are
successful in carrying out the plan you
just outlined what does the us do or do
they not have any options
uh great great question so part of it is
what what he said this morning right
we
will protect taiwan at all costs
really you want to provoke
the the other major nuclear superpower
well we already provoked russia so why
not provoke china too
um
and look you've been in in the
conference room in in chapel hill right
we have a map in the table we have four
conference rooms brazil russia india
china and then we have a global map in
the in the boardroom and they were made
in china and the global map there's no
uk which is clearly intentional because
they hate the uk because of hong kong
and the china map
taiwan is part of china
right there's no question that that map
includes taiwan so they view taiwan as
china and we view them as a separate
country so
we'll continue to do stuff like that to
antagonize a little bit
but at the end of the day what can we do
we owe them a lot of money
they owe they own over a trillion
dollars of our debt
technically we have to pay them back
yeah it's crazy debtors usually lose
over the long term creditors win debtors
lose yeah
another topic that i've seen people
talking about is uh gdp and debt ratio
uh it's a about i don't know 130 percent
you know ballpark uh at the moment and
obviously everyone always talk about
paying back the debt pay it back pay
back payback uh and i think you're
highlighting like that's probably not
nearly as uh as possible or realistic as
maybe people want it to be uh but
another thing that we could do to uh
affect that number is to grow the
economy and it feels like the the growth
component almost grow your way out uh
almost never gets discussed in any
meaningful way some of that's because
you know obviously in q1 and kind of our
hindsight bias or recency bias
negative 1.4 percent uh gdp annualized
so like if we're already negative
doesn't feel like we're gonna you know
start growing anytime soon but
what is the realistic nature or like is
it possible for us just to do a 180 on
growth of the gdp and on the economy and
that would help us at least alleviate
some of the pain here again really good
idea really good idea
short run
no chance here's why so
gdp growth
is equal to working age population
growth plus productivity working age
population growth we know with precision
for the next 30 years
because right you can't make people age
faster
i guess we could invent something to do
that but you can't well actually you can
open up your borders and let a lot of
older people in not old people but older
like 20s and 30s that actually is a
great thing to do and it's how countries
can
uh in fact go up to me i would send
airplanes to chingua university and iit
in india and i say all you phds get on
board come on we got free land for you
start a business we'll give you loans
that's what i would do but no one asked
me
so
yes you can grow but not in the next
decade next decade we're going to have
sub 2 gdp growth because we know working
age population growth to the second
decimal point is going to be sub 1
we know productivity is going to hover
around percent because again aging
population bad demographics
when the when the millennials the echo
boomers start to turn 45
that's when we might get a little more
productivity back because 45 to 65 year
olds are actually really productive
uh because they've learned their
business and their their you know
they're in their peak spending years
the other thing we could do
but we're not going to do it anytime
soon is we could focus on innovation
innovation
is how you create wealth innovation is
how you grow
uh you know you and i talk about this
all the time right there are four asset
classes that people talk about that you
talk about on the best business show
right stocks bonds currencies
commodities that's it and he says oh
what about hedge funds nope hedge funds
on stocks bonds currencies commodities
oh what about private equity young
common stock preferred stock convertible
bond what about real estate i own equity
of the debt the equity of the deal the
debt of the deal or the land the
commodity there are four assets
but all of those
come
from innovation without innovation we
get no new companies no new formation of
assets no new
you know uh
growth and so
we could if we were smart like singapore
what does singapore do they took their
social security
and they put into an entity called
temasek
ngic government singapore and then they
invest in the smartest growth businesses
around the world
and so they don't have a massive
unfunded hole in their uh
liabilities
so
we could do the same thing in fact again
for up to me
i would take
a trillion dollars literally trillion
dollars they can print them all over the
place and i'd put it in a fund
and i would
hand it out as venture capital to the
smartest entrepreneurs in the united
states
to build businesses and then we would
get a growth spurt as you described that
would help
now it wouldn't totally fix because we
got the aging population problem and the
unfunded liabilities problem social
security medicare we can fix
social security we should extend out the
retirement age because people are
working longer hard to fix
medicare but we could we could again
that's a long answer to your your really
figure something out though
yeah and and i think a huge piece of
this is uh it does feel like uh
for the last couple of years uh the tech
industry uh got built up put on a
pedestal you know literally movies the
social network like all this stuff
and then the last i don't know three
four five years they've been taking a
beating from the mainstream media and
all of a sudden now it's been uh look at
the scams look at the zeros look at the
stupid founders doing all these dumb
things and like to be clear there was
definitely zeros and scams and founders
doing dumb things or whatever
always but on a net basis it's like
shouldn't we want all of our children to
be like these problem solvers
right like like isn't that how we solve
problems in our society so like i don't
i don't know you've been doing this
longer than i could go
you know my passion i know it's your
passion too
early childhood education we do it all
wrong right our whole education system
is designed to create factory workers
we don't have factories anymore we don't
produce anything what we need are kids
who can problem solve kids who can
collaborate kids who can't i'll give
true true story so my little guy so you
know we have the two older kids and then
the caboose we took our little guy seven
years ago to his tryout for
for uh kindergarten for this this uh
nice private school here and
uh
a whole day literally a whole day
four-year-olds in this this room and
they we had we noticed some some
behaviors i'm like oh what well you know
will didn't like to sit on his square
like i don't want my four-year-old to
ever sit on a square are you joking
stop oh
what else oh well he was walking around
the room picking things up and looking
at them
oh my god he's creative he's curious
seriously
so obviously we don't go to that school
but the point is
if we
teach problem solving if we put people
in positions to lead if we put people in
positions to create they will create
they will lead
you know
unfortunately we're ruled by a political
class
and that political class only cares
about being in power and so they they
cut anything they cut head start right
number one indicator whether you go to
prison
score on the second grade reading test
number one indicator of whether you
spend time in prison is how low you
score in the second grader we can fix
that that's easy to fix
maybe we can't create a whole bunch of
great entrepreneurs but we can fix those
problems
and once you fix the base level problems
then we can focus on this creativity
this innovation and growth
and maybe we can't grow our way
completely out of it because the mess
we're in
but we can certainly have a shot
and i'd rather take a shot it feels like
that's the only thing that we can
control right because to your point the
the political class the laptop class you
know whatever you want to call the these
uh individuals uh they're in control
either through elections or appointed
positions they're going to continue to
play the game if you got a money printer
you're incentivized to print the money
and so what is the only thing that the
you know average entrepreneur or
investor can do it's literally try to
grow right and that is the only
contribution that you can have well and
the other thing and again i don't want
to go too far down this rabbit hole but
but it's this whole backlash against you
know the billionaire class and the
wealthy
the wealthy are not the problem
the wealthy create businesses they
create jobs they create livelihoods they
inspire they lead
our problem is the bureaucrats
that that feed
off
the wealthy
and you know like this latest thing
where they're going to tax
corporations to solve inflation
are you kidding me
and you know
it's just
basic economics aside that's just a
stupid idea
first thing you mean that raising the
cost to run a business
is actually going to make them lower
their prices
exactly right
so look the first thing is we should
never tax income
anyway right we should never tax wealth
creation innovation
we should tax consumption
everyone should earn whatever they want
to earn and then when you consume you
get taxed you can't cheat there are no
loopholes there are no special interest
groups
you know when i bought this shirt i paid
tax i didn't care about it i just paid
the tax if i want to buy a fancy car i
pay more tax if i want to drive my kia
and pay less tax i love my kia so
the thing is
what we should have is a focus on
creativity creation innovation
and
by doing so
looked at the massive fortunes that have
been created he says oh you know bezos
he's he's so wealthy he needs to pay his
fair share are you kidding he's paid way
more than his fair share and by the way
he employs four
million people
and i love telstra my two nephews
both had to drop out of college couldn't
quite handle the rigor or the not the
rigor they couldn't handle the
environment right they're more free
spirit big thinkers long story short
they i know with their father-in-law but
they they got some help but but they
have created a business that amazon uses
to
tape the floors of their warehouses so
the robots know where to go
they're making millions of dollars a
year in revenue
i love that i love that story
that is real that is
tangible
and and they are good citizens and they
are good contributors and they are
they're inspirational to other people
that know them to hey wait a minute i
can start a business like i can do
something myself i don't have to go to
work for this you know nine to five
thing
and not everybody can be an entrepreneur
that's not my point
but we can all aspire and we can all
help and we can all contribute we can
all you know
push
those entrepreneurs to do great things
i could not agree more uh the last thing
i want to talk to you about is uh during
these market downturns we obviously see
stocks down uh crypto real estate bond i
mean just everything is going down and
uh you know it uh goes back to this idea
it's all one trade the fed's in control
and they're gonna drive this stuff down
until they feel like uh people have
capitulated uh what are institutional
investors thinking about right now when
they're watching this play out obviously
they have some direct investing they
have uh probably much more uh kind of
investing through general partners and
through fund managers but like what's
going through the heads of these
institutional investors right now
so it's it's a
it's a great question that
you have to answer it in pieces there
are
really great institutional investors i
was just with you know the fairfax folks
that you and i know well uh last
thursday up in dc so you can think about
this in the midst of all of this turmoil
markets crashing you said every asset
going down
they called together
all of their private investors venture
capital growth equity buyouts
energy
uh
and put us all in a room together for a
day on thursday and just had a massive
idea session
genius right take people you're paying
lots of money to do smart things for you
and let's see if there's some
opportunities that come out of all this
turmoil and they got some really good
ideas so the really smart ones like
katherine and andy are going to do that
kind of stuff
the
the the less smart ones
are going to do what human beings do
human beings do two things really really
well
we buy what we wish we would have bought
and we sell we're about to need
you and i debated this this morning
actually um
so
the problem with
uh
most investors
an institution is a little bit less but
they're just as guilty as the
individuals the individuals are the
worst about this right they constantly
buy the top and then they sell the
bottom but the institutions also chase
hot dots
and so there are some institutions that
are looking around saying well there are
no hot dots so what do i do
so
they are
probably selling some things like all
the the nasty stuff about the hedge
funds and the tiger cubs and all that
stuff there are people they're going to
try to redeem from those things that's
probably a mistake
um one of the things about investing
that that i tried to live and i was
actually decent at it but not not
perfect um
but
what you should do
you should never buy something that has
had a hot three-year period
you should sell that because it's going
to mean revert what you should do is
find somebody who has a great 10-year
track record
who's just had a terrible
one two three-year run like and the
worse the better
and give that person money so there are
some that are out there doing that and
those are the the real geniuses
i think the last thing is
i i think some of this being talked
about at the institutional level a lot
right now
is the same thing as being talked about
at the individual level which is well
wait a second this is different what
about all these assets that were
supposed to be uncorrelated why are they
all going down at the same time i
thought bonds were supposed to not go
down as stocks went down they're
supposed to be a safe haven i thought
gold was supposed to be a safe haven i
thought you know crypto is supposed to
be a safe haven i thought international
stocks weren't supposed to be correlated
with u.s stocks well here's the problem
the everything bubble which was the
result of the excessive central bank
liquidity around the world caused all
assets to move to stupidville right you
mentioned the market cap to gdp right
worse than 2 000 price to sales ratio
worse than 2000. so equities got to
stupidville bonds listen to greg foss on
twitter right rail about this got to
stupidville
and
everything commodities and all of it
went up and so what happened is when
they cut off the liquidity
the first thing started to correct
well the problem this time was people
didn't just buy with cash they bought
with margin
everybody bought with margin even some
of the institutions bought with margin
because the goldman sachses and others
for trademark were given them margin
and so we had the highest margin ever in
history well in it when you get a margin
call right your stock falls 20 you get a
margin call you're supposed to put in
more money
you don't get to sell what you want to
sell you sell what you have to sell you
sell what's most liquid so that's what
causes everything to fall you saw it in
march of 2020 and you've seen it in the
last two three weeks here
and when that starts to happen people
start questioning the whole theory of
diversification now marco it's won the
nobel prize in it i have a t-shirt says
markowitz was right and it does work but
in the short run it gets temporarily
suspended and i think that does prompt
some people to make bad decisions so you
got to avoid that urge
to make those bad decisions
and you know i've said this to many
others many other times but investing i
think literally is the only business i
know
when things go on sale people run out of
the store
and the cheaper the price the further
they run
think about any other business you put
wedding dresses on sale
they all run in the store they don't run
out of the store they run in the store
when you think about uh prices going up
of assets there's lots of talk about
hold them they're compounding you know
the charlie monger warren buffett never
interrupt compounding unnecessarily then
there's another school of thought of
rebalancing and kind of hitting your uh
allocation target percentages etc
what do the institutions do on the way
down are they rebalancing are they uh uh
trying to
take let's say a pension fund as an
example like do they try to maybe not
pay out as fast or what what are like
the tactical things that they do on the
way down that maybe people aren't aware
of uh where they're trying to
essentially stop the bleeding maybe or
at least address the problem
yep now again two really important
points so one is is the rebalancing the
good ones right the swenson acolytes etc
you know rest in peace david um they do
rebalance and and that was something
that
i was always really proud of the way we
did that at carolina and at notre dame
is is we're very active rebounds because
when you're in the endowment business or
the pension business you're not in the
get-rich business concentration makes
you rich diversification keeps you rich
and rebalancing keeps you richer
because you're constantly buying cheap
and selling deer
um all great fortunes in the world came
from concentration
how do you create a small fortune start
with a large fortune and stay
concentrated so there will always be
cycles
and if you can hold forever right in a
tax-deferred structure like berkshire
you should do that but you should lever
up that's what they do but most people
should just constantly rebalance with a
good plan they should have some
get-rich-money i would say you should
have three buckets liquidity bucket to
fund your lifestyle a get-rich-bucket to
do all the fun stuff the friends condo
deal the brother-in-law's advantage
you're gonna lose it all anyway so just
make it small and then stay rich bucket
diversify that and these institutions
are looking at that stay rich bucket and
saying okay my equities just fell a lot
my tech equities fell more let's go buy
some stuff that's on sale maybe buy some
chinese equities maybe buy some of these
these cloud companies although i think
the cloud companies are still too
expensive
um
then on the flip side they're looking at
their private port and here's the one
problem
the very best of the very best
the yales the notre dame's the you know
unc's etcetera the very best of the very
best in performance they have this lag
problem
the public markets adjust immediately
and then you have a denominator problem
because your private markets don't
adjust and so you have a denominator
problem and that your total fund value
went down so your weighting in private
went up but you can't really sell unless
you sell in the secondary market and
you're going to take a massive haircut
because there's very little liquidity so
doing that doesn't make any sense so you
have to actually talk to your el to your
gps and say well how far
are valuations actually going to fall
because they're going to fall
but they'll be sticky down instead of
immediate because in private it's the
escalator up
i mean in public is the escalator up in
the elevator down
right in the private world it's the
escalator up and the escalator down it
just takes longer to come down what's
your read on a lot of the major hedge
funds so we've seen entire global d1 you
know a whole bunch of it's not just any
one of them uh obviously the more tech
oriented or growth oriented they were
the more their public losses uh seemed
to be uh but also they'd start to push
into the private market
and
you know i've heard some of them are
pausing private investing some of them
are drastically slowing some of them
have even said hey we're getting out of
that business like
just walk me through if uh one of these
major hedge funds like what are some of
the things that they're dealing with
right now that maybe people aren't aware
of
oh so i mean
lots of issues uh one some of these guys
have been so incredibly successful you
know
entire global is a great example you
know they they had a had a 30 billion
hedge fund but they also had 70 billion
in private investments across 13 or 14
funds i remember you know when we gave
them dollars six and seven million and
when they were just starting as tiger
tech and they were teeny tiny and that
that firm is is one of the great
investors of all time and this year
notwithstanding
you know they overstayed their welcome
on the long side you know like a lot of
hedge funds they let their hedges down
because for 10 years in the qe era
it didn't pay to hedge right if you
shorted anything
they came after you and they squeezed
you and you know we've all seen the meme
stocks you know stories and and melvin
and all that stuff but
it was just really hard to short and so
what tends to happen unfortunately we
we've seen this now in two different
cycles we saw it in the 2008 nine cycle
and we're seeing it again now
unlike the 2000 2001 cycle which i'll
talk about in a second but this time
what happened is is the the pressure was
so
incredible against the short side is
that hedge funds came into this
deleveraging the largest net long they'd
been a long time so they're taking it on
the chin there now the good news is most
of them you can't get out right
literally you can't get out for three
four five years to get all your money
back so they'll be fine
um on the private side
i think the good ones
will will continue and i just thought
co-2 just did another great deal today
i think the good ones will continue to
do well i think the ones that were
tourists that were trying it because
everyone else was doing it they're done
i think they're going to be out because
they reneged on some deals in the stress
period or the last six months and their
reputation suffered because of it i
don't think they'll be
invited back a deal that we did uh with
someone who shall remain nameless you
know referred to them as cap table
hackers
you know that's those are strong um
the other piece i'll talk about is
this this idea that
you know hedged with a d
matters so if you go back to 2000 to
2002 and i will argue that we're in 2001
again i call it the 2001 redo so we had
the tech bubble and everybody forgot
about hedging and the d got lost
and most hedge funds
got whacked in 2001 2002 but there were
a handful most of them tiger cubs uh and
some soros acolytes and a few others
that actually had a capital d and they
did great
and the thing i'm probably most proud of
in my whole career is from 2000 2002
when the markets were down 40
and
the average endowment was down 25
we at carolina were dead flat
yeah they didn't make any money so i
don't break my arm pat myself on the
back we didn't make any money but we
didn't um
we didn't uh lose any money and that
goes to your second point which is true
in downturns
endowments foundations well foundations
can't do it endowments can do it
foundations have to spend five percent a
year because of tax code but endowments
have something called a rolling 12
quarter average of their market value
and so as the market value declines they
will pay out less to preserve capital so
they can buy the cheaper stuff and that
does make sense now again it doesn't
help
like in 2002 i remember colleges having
to cancel scholarships and cancel
professorships that's painful so thing
again most proud of is we never had to
cut spending at carolina so if you
do constantly rebalance
which was one of the hardest thing i
remember arguing with my board you'll
love the story so
march
february of 2000 i go in and say guys we
need to rebalance like what do you mean
rebalance
so well we're at 36
in in domestic equity we're supposed to
be at 25. well what do you mean supposed
to be so well the investment guideline i
mean the investment policy i called the
investment policy the investor policy oh
we're the board you know you brought
that investment policy we don't even
like the word policy change that word to
guideline okay fine change the guideline
didn't get selected come back in may
market started to roll over
like all right fine you can take the
allocation back to the top end of the
the guidelines
but uh no more because these are our
best managers you know they did so great
the last year in 2000 like okay by
september they're like get that [ __ ] out
of here and remember that thing change
it back to policy we like the word
policy
it is uh it's incredible how uh this you
could literally be talking about right
now right like we are talking about
right now yeah we're talking about right
now it is 2000 because what's happening
right now all the fraud
right all the corporate fraud all the
griff all the stealing is being exposed
just like in 2001 enron worldcom
cisco had to restate all their earnings
just like they just oh well maybe we
overstated some inventory and
so
the problem is people forget 2002 was
the bad year
2002 was the down 23 year so i'm not i'm
not saying we have to go there
but if we make policy decisions
that exacerbate the problem
we could go there
so i think it's a good place to uh to
wrap up with my last question which is
as of right now
give or take the market is pricing in
what will be 10 rate hikes in uh
interest rates and
that we will reach a 300 basis point
interest rate by the end of the year
uh i don't think that you believe that
that is going to happen but you can
confirm that uh i take the under okay
the way under and so what do you think
is likely to happen do we get
five
three where do we end up as an interest
rate at the end of the year
look i
i was
correct
in
march
when i said no way 50
lucky if he does 25
i was incorrect
in may i said no way 50 no way 75 no way
75 and no way 50 i thought maybe another
25. he did 50. surprisingly um
if you put my feet to the fire pump i'd
say he's done i think the pal pivot is
coming any day now
and uh he just there's just no way
i think he needs a couple
prints on cpi to roll over you know as
oil prices stop going up and his used
car prices start to to media
ameliorate because that's really 75
percent of the cpi increase
i think if he gets two months of of kind
of flat to down he can back off
i'll say five this year you know half as
many as the market expects and i think
maybe we get to a buck and a quarter
maybe yeah i don't think there's any
maybe get a buck and a half maybe half
and half so five and a buck and a half
so i'm biased in this last question
because uh i think this is gonna happen
but do you think we get an interest rate
cut before the end of the year
i do i do yeah i i think
i think this fall is gonna be
bad i don't think you can go into a
midterm election
with uh any level of inflation
uh would be bad but the thing that's
worse than that is a recession
yeah look
you're exactly right i mean we know for
a fact that the number one indicator
of success of the president's party is
gasoline prices
number one i mean inverse relationship
low gas prices they sweep high gas
prices they get swept out and right now
at 7 50 in california they're out i mean
like like
they're all out
if they could they'd get rid of the
president in the midterm at 7.50 i mean
just done uh
and then the second thing we know
is
that they actually can control
oil prices if they can get saudi to play
ball now
arguably saudi doesn't want to play ball
because they won't return his call but
if they could get saudi to pump they
could get oil prices to roll over that
would collapse cpi
and that would get people thinking that
we'd be out of the woods on a recession
but remember recession doesn't mean
back-to-back quarters of negative gdp
okay that's why i think we're in 2001
2001 first quarter was down 1.3 kind of
similar to this year second quarter was
actually positive third quarter
was negative exacerbated by 911 i'm not
saying we're gonna have a nine eleven
and then fourth quarter was slightly
positive the year was one percent but
anything sub one and a half is a
recession and so i think we're gonna
have the same kind of mild recession
barring
bad decisions right we put up more
tariffs
it gets worse we
do lockdowns
much worse so
there could be some policy errors that
make it worse but i'm with you i think
uh
we're gonna it's gonna be very clear
that we're in a recession i think we're
already in
uh and whether it turns from a garden
variety recession
into a depression i'll leave you with
one depressing point in 1840
the government made a number of policy
decisions that turned a guard variety
recession into a depression in the 1930s
government made two policy decisions uh
raising rates and smoot-hawley that
turned a garden variety recession into
the great depression
now we're 90 years later there's a
90-year cycle go back and read about it
uh
[Music]
jd jd gann
um
and
i
i don't think it necessarily has to
happen
but
the picture of the ships
off the ports in china
actually scared me
that was actually a frightening picture
because i know how close we are in
just-in-time inventory and how broken
the system is and then you throw on top
of that you know wheat production
problems and all things you talk about
your your daily newsletter
again don't have to have a depression
but it's not
a zero probability
yeah
it's a it's crazy to me i mean the the
uh if you had said in 2020
when uh
biden got elected if we would be here in
this situation i think very few people
would have put a high probability on it
but what's even crazier to me
is regardless of your politics
the sitting u.s president in the latest
poll it's like two out of every 10
americans think we're headed in the
right direction it's like forget who the
president is forget political parties
forget like to me it's just like
yeah man that is a low low low number
because usually you just expect kind of
like partisan politics right it's like
oh okay you know my person's in cool i'm
cool with whatever we're doing oh the
other person's in i'm not cool with it
so you get kind of like a 50 50 maybe we
get like a 60 40 in either direction
but a 20 80
is not what you would expect not what
you want not to expect
and
i'll i can't leave you with the other
frightening thing
i used to say when
when w
was proximate to the cheney presidency
i knew who to be afraid of
right i mean dick was in charge and we
all knew and that was fine and i you
know i love w he's a great guy a little
faux pas recently was pretty wild but
but i think he's an interesting guy
now i don't know who to be afraid of
because it ain't it ain't the guy
sitting in the main seat and ain't the
woman in the back seat so i just don't
know who to be afraid of and that that
makes me more afraid than
ever because if i don't know who to be
afraid of i don't know what to expect if
i don't know what to expect i don't know
how to prepare
and so
i think
again for people thinking about this or
listening to it or watching it the way
to prepare
is to have a lot of personal liquidity
right have more liquidity than you
normally would
have a little bit of
kind of running money
uh
and and and you know we made it the
whole time pump without saying bitcoin i
am impressed
i mean the whole show without saying but
but you gotta own a little you just have
to
if uh people understand the problem the
solution becomes more obvious my friend
ah there you go
at the beginning you said how you're
gonna finish and you just did i love it
uh all right where can we send people to
find you on the internet or learn more
about what you guys are doing uh across
all the different vehicles at morgan
creek
yeah so uh morgan creek cap cap.com is
the website uh morgan creek capital
management and morgan creek digital and
then uh at mark usco
on twitter
my dms actually do work i stink at most
every other form of communication but
the dm i am not too bad texting i'm
actually pretty good too but i'm not
going to give that number out
[Laughter]
all right well i appreciate you you
coming on uh i always enjoy talking to
you about what's going on in the world
because uh i think there's just more and
more craziness which leads to more more
complexity and so as you unpack it it
becomes uh
just fascinating to think about
well i you know we don't get to do it
often enough we talk all the time but we
don't get to do this
nearly as often as as i i would like i
have loved our conversations over the
the many years and uh appreciate the
invite tonight of course thanks so much